meine Kollegin Brigitte Saar
recherchiert seit 25 Jahren über
tiefseeexpeditionen sie war selbst vor
einigen Jahren mit einem tauch U-Boot
beim Wrack der Titanic und hat zwei der
Piloten interviewt die jetzt an Bord der
Titan waren muss man ja wohl sagen guten
Abend Brigitte es gibt wohl tatsächlich
keine Hoffnung mehr oder ja also die
Erkenntnisse heute sind eindeutig wenn
also Trümmerteile die zu dieser
Druckkammer zu diesem Kernbereich von so
einem U-Boot gehören gefunden wurden
dann gibt es keine Schutzzone mehr in
der noch Menschen sein können dann ist
dieses Tauchboot irgendwann an Sonntag
vermutlich dann implodiert
ja Brigitte was können wir denn jetzt
daraus schließen über das was wir heute
gesehen haben erlebt haben diese
Trümmerteile was möglicherweise passiert
ist
also es gibt jetzt im Moment mit der
Erkenntnis von heute gibt es zwei
denkbare Szenarien man hat ja vor
zwischen einer Stunde 45 und zwei
Stunden nach tauchbeginn den Kontakt zum
Schiff verloren zum zum Mini-U-Boot und
das muss ja dann im Prinzip schon der
Moment gewesen sein muss da irgendwie
Probleme gab und dann gibt's die
Variante das schon diese allerersten
Probleme so gravierend waren dass da an
der Stelle es einen Riss in diesem
Druckkörper gegeben hat und das Boot
schon explodiert ist möglicherweise noch
bevor es überhaupt am Meeresboden war
oder das ist da Probleme hat hatte dann
weiter in Richtung Meeresboden
abgesunken ist und weil man das Schiff
irgendwie nicht mehr steuern konnte weil
die Kapsel im Prinzip dann schon
führungslos war hat man auch nicht mehr
sanft abbremsen können bevor man am
Meeresboden aufsetzt ist also mit sehr
viel Wucht aufgesetzt und hat dabei
vielleicht die Kapsel so beschädigt dass
auch der Druck zu viel wurde und das
implodiert wurde diese zwei Szenarien
kann man sich mit den Trümmern die man
jetzt gefunden hat eigentlich noch
vorstellen ist denn das jetzt eine
Tragödie die irgendwann passieren musste
oder anders gefragt wie problematisch
war diese Konstruktion des
das ist schwer zu beurteilen weil wir ja
immer noch nicht wissen was da jetzt
genau versagt hat aber ja diese Kapsel
war im Vergleich zu den Kapseln anderer
Betreiber anderer Forschungsinstitute
die ja seit Jahren und damit eigentlich
auch sehr sicher Forschung und Tiefsee
Tauchgänge betreiben wirklich
signifikant anders alle anderen Kapseln
die wir so kennen hatten eine
Druckkammer die aus Metall war und die
als Kugel konzipiert war und eine Kugel
ist ein Körper der Druck sehr gut
verteilen kann und nun dachte man eben
man kann das anders machen das ist eine
Röhre die Druckverteilung auf der Röhre
ist anders und die Röhre war nicht aus
Metall sondern aus Carbonfasern
gewickelt und es gab vor zwei drei
Jahren als diese Kapsel auch in Dienst
gestellt wurde schon mal den Hinweis
dass der Druck bei diesen ständigen
Wechsel mal an der Oberfläche kein Druck
mal ganz tief im Wasser viel Druck
möglicherweise dazu führen könnte dass
es in diesen gewickelten Carbonfasern so
Mikro Risse gibt und die zwar am Anfang
gut hält aber möglicherweise über die
Jahre mit mehreren Einsätzen immer mehr
so mini Bruchstellen hat und mürbe wird
also es kann schon sein dass dieses
Konstrukt was physikalisch auf dem
Papier erstmal hält und was ja auch
mehrere Expeditionen durchgehalten hat
dass das am Ende doch das falsche war
für diesen permanenten krassen Wechsel
zwischen viel Druck und keinem Druck ist
dieses Unglück diese ganz
offensichtliche Tragödie jetzt das Ende
für den Tauchtourismus Titanic Wrack
vermutlich schon zum einen aus ganz
praktischen Gründen die Firma ist weg
das U-Boot ist weg der Firmengründer der
ja auch der treibende Mann hinter all
diesen Ideen war es weg und das zweite
ist natürlich welche Kunden will man
denn jetzt noch für so eine Tauchfahrt
begeistern also selbst wenn es jetzt ein
neues U-Boot gäbe dass man baut und das
für so einen kommerziellen Tauchgang
gemacht ist dann müsste man ja wieder
Abenteuer lustige Multimillionäre finden
die bereit sind da einzusteigen und
dafür Geld zu zahlen und ich gehe davon
aus dass die Warteliste für so eine
Expedition sehr kurz wäre auf der
anderen Seite möglicherweise gibt es ja
tatsächlich solche abenteuerlustigen
Multimillionäre tatsächlich noch da
schließlich noch eine Frage vielleicht
auch eine ganz persönliche Frage an dich
an Brigitte fragen sich ja viele
tatsächlich warum macht man sowas
überhaupt mit sich in so eine enge Röhre
zu zwingen 4000 Meter unter dem Meer wo
kann da die Faszination liegen
also man möchte natürlich mit eigenen
Augen dieses Frack erleben mit eigenen
Augen ist irgendwie immer intensiver als
Bücher zu sehen Fotos zu sehen
Dokumentationen zu sehen dieses
unmittelbare dort sein dabei sein in den
letzten Jahren gehört natürlich auch
dazu dass man damit dann vielleicht
irgendwie was darstellt ja in im
Zeitalter von Instagram und selbst
Inszenierung ist es natürlich auch etwas
was man nach der Reise womit man ein
bisschen angeben kann
aber die genaue Motivation eines jeden
Einzelnen ist eine andere für mich was
damals wirklich die Leidenschaft für
diesen diesen Teil der Geschichte aber
ich muss natürlich auch sagen als ich
getaucht bin gab es noch nie einen
tödlichen Vorfall mit den Insassen von
einer solchen Tiefsee Tauchkapsel und
das hat sich natürlich jetzt schlagartig
geändert das hat sich geändert auf jeden
Fall Brigitte sagt ganz herzlichen Dank
für diese hoch interessante Analyse auch
heute Abend wieder Danke Brigitte